here's how I break this down
I love somebody who bets on themselves
like Francis that's what he's doing here
if I sit back and I take my uh
admiration for Francis zagano out of the
equation and I sit in Dana White seat or
the UFC's brass seat and I think to
myself why wouldn't this deal get done
the UFC is banking on they were banking
on Jon Jones beating Francis agano so
let's say in this crazy world we live in
John were to beat Francis
what do you do with Francis let's say
John holds on to that belt for three to
four fights Francis loses to John beats
one guy gets another shot loses to him
you're not going to pay that you're not
gonna give that guy the world
you're just not you're not so the whole
Dana thing and the UFC went we're gonna
bet on John